RETO MEIER: Hi, there.
My name is Reto Meier, and I'm
usually joined on the App
Clinic by Ian Ni-Lewis.
But the preparation for this
week's show required us to do
some intense physical exercise
in order to properly test
personal fitness
apps Endomondo,
runtastic, and RunKeeper.
We chose to test these
apps hiking.
Now, back in Australia, we call
hiking "walking," but
folks in California seem to be
more inclined to drive if
they're going anywhere further
than the nearest car park.
But in any case, the last time
I saw Ian was deep in the
backwoods of the Big Basin
National Park.
Anyway, find out what features
and technical tips and tricks
it takes to make a killer
personal fitness app today--
on "The App Clinic."
So one of the big benefits of
living in the Bay Area is that
there's really a limitless
supply of hiking trails all
within a really short drive.
Now, being a certified
practicing geek, the only
thing more fun than hiking
through the wilderness is
tracking my route
while doing so.
So all three of today's apps
will let me do that, and a few
other things as well.
So all three of today's apps
support a standard set of
functionality, which is
what I've put up here.
Now, they're all designed to
allow you to track a workout.
And in this case, they're
optimized for something
running related, basically any
exercise which can be measured
through a combination of the
distance you've traveled and
the amount of time it's taken.
Now, accordingly, they measure
the duration of your workout
and the distance traveled and
use that to work out things
like your pace, average speed,
calories burned, water
consumed, all those
sorts of things.
And they also use the GPS
information that they track
throughout your workout to
display your route on a map.
And each of the apps shows a
slightly different set of
details on the map
and, in fact, in
terms of your workout.
And I'll go through each of
those as we look at the apps
in a little more detail.
They each also allow you to
select the activity that
you're doing and choose from
a selection of different
workouts, so that could be
running, jogging, rowing,
cycling, push-ups, whatever
you like.
And there's different styles
of workouts as well.
So it could be a one-off,
a time trial versus your
friends, any number of different
workout styles.
And again, I'll show you what
some of these apps have to
offer as we go through
them in detail.
So taking these features as a
baseline, as a given, this is
basically what your personal
fitness tracking app needs to
have in order to
be in the game.
Let's take a look at some of the
features that can really
help differentiate those apps
from their competitors.
So this is my wish list of
things that I'd like to see in
personal fitness apps.
So there's a bunch of stuff on
this list that's totally in
the nice-to-have territory.
So things like a rich tablet
experience and analytics are
the sort of that can really lift
an app well beyond its
competitors, well beyond sort of
what you would expect from
an app, which is really going to
help you win over fans, win
over users, which are going to
be coming back to your app and
really become addicted to it.
But let's face it, these
features are the sorts of
things which people aren't going
to notice straightaway.
They're going to require a
certain amount of discovery.
Now, why is that important?
Well, as it happens, I was
hiking in Rancho San Antonio a
couple of weeks ago when my wife
asked me if there was a
way that we could track how far
we were going and how long
we would be hiking for.
And I thought, you know what?
There's probably some apps
to help with that.
So I jumped straight on to our
suggestions on the Trello
board and installed the first
three apps that were there,
and that is, in fact,
the three apps which
we're looking at today.
Now, the factors that I used
to decide which app we were
going to actually keep running
was how quickly it let me get
started with the confidence that
it was going to record
everything that I
wanted it to.
So a quick startup and
an intuitive--
dare I say--
obvious controls were
really critical.
So the overall look and
feel were really
important here as well.
I opened each app and literally
spent 5 seconds
looking at each of them before
I chose which one I was going
to go with.
So that gives you a really
good idea of just how
important it is to make that
great first impression.
I'm not alone in the way
that I look at my apps.
People will just download them
and figure, well, which of
these three am I going to use?
Eh, this one kind of looks like
it's the best, so they're
going to go with it.
So in the end, for me, I ended
up choosing Endomondo.
So they've got a beautiful
feature page here, which has a
perfectly distinctive icon.
Now, it doesn't necessarily say
too much about the app,
but it's quite clear that you're
not going to mistake
that icon for anything else,
anyone else's icon.
And it fits in really nice
into their bigger logo as
well, so it's a really
good example.
So we really got off onto
the right foot here.
I looked at this and thought
this looks legit.
This looks like an app that
people have spent a little bit
of time and effort on.
So let's jump ahead here.
So when you open up the app,
what you get is this really
well-designed home screen.
It's totally intuitive.
It leaves me with absolutely no
question as to what I need
to do to get started.
There's a giant green start
button that draws your
attention straightaway and is
a great example of when and
how to create custom controls
within your app.
The rest of the app looks
pretty standard.
They've got a clean white
design with a
standard action bar.
And what I really like about
this design is its simplicity.
The layout isn't cluttered.
You have three pieces of
information about your workout
visible at any time, along with
the exercise that you're
planning to do and the workout
style that you're
planning to engage in.
There's even a hint of
the map poking out
along the bottom corner.
And if I switch to the giant
phone, I can show you a couple
of other nice features
of the app.
All right, giant phone,
excellent.
I'm going to switch to the other
side here, because my
cables aren't long enough.
So if I fire up Endomondo,
you can see here that--
we choose not to go Pro.
I didn't install the Pro version
here simply because I
didn't use the Pro version
when I was using
the app on the road.
I'm going to try and unplug
this and put it back in.
Hopefully, it will
stop flickering.
Or it'll go away entirely,
one of the two.
There we go, still flickering.
What do you think, Daniel?
Anything we can do here
or just persevere?
DANIEL: Why don't you persevere
for a second.
I'm going to see if--
actually, I'm going to go right
over there and try to
mess with the connection
really quick.
Just give me 10 seconds.
RETO MEIER: Sure.
I'll talk, and I'm going to
stand in front of the giant--
well, that's going to be
pretty annoying, but
nonetheless.
What you'll find--
in fact, if I jump a step back,
that's going to make it
easier for us.
And if you want to just switch
that off for a second.
So you can see straightaway
that the
layout isn't clustered.
And what we've got here is,
alongside each of the options
on the screen, you can see
that there's a little
drop-down, which is in fact
going to allow you-- it gives
you a hint that clicking on any
of them is actually going
to do something.
It's going to let you choose
you're options differently.
And this is really useful,
because straightaway it gives
me hints as to how I'm going to
be able to use this app in
the right way.
So straightaway, you know that
the clicking on stuff is going
to give me options
to change things.
And in fact, that's exactly
how it works.
And so if I click on any of
those options what I get
straightaway is a list of
alternative things that I can
look at, so whether that be
looking at calories consumed
rather than distance
traveled or any of
those sorts of options.
And the same thing goes for
the workout style and the
workout activity that
I'm planning to do.
Right away, you're able to
choose, click the drop-down
and see, oh, actually,
I'm rowing.
And when I click on those,
I actually get nice, big,
full-screen activities
rather than pop-ups.
And this is kind of important
because it makes it really
simple for me to be able to
make those choices without
being overly distracted, which
is really, really useful.
And that's really the way
that the whole UI
design for the app works.
It's really intuitive.
It's really fast
to get started,
which is a real benefit.
So I'm going to spin
this around.
If we hold it real tight,
it looks like it gets--
DANIEL: Yeah, I think it's the
movement on the device.
RETO MEIER: Movement
on the device.
DANIEL: You know, it's
the issues with MHL.
So are there any Miracast OEMs
out there that are producing
products which are Miracast
compatible?
Get on it so we can start using
Nexus 4 to do our demos.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
All right, so that's hugely
disappointing that that's
working out that way.
But nonetheless, I
will continue on.
We have do have screenshots
for most of it.
So the other important thing
is that this-- yeah, let's
just kill that because that's
just way too annoying.
So again, it's really important
that you're likely
to be using this app outside
in direct sunlight, when
you're in a hurry.
So you really don't want to have
to read small text and
hit small touch targets.
You want everything to
be as simple and
easy to use as possible.
And basically, everything
in the app
goes along those lines.
It's really simple to use,
really straightforward to be
able to select different
elements within the
UI, which is great.
Wow, it seems that our technical
difficulties have
scared off most people, which
is a shame, but nonetheless.
So that's basically how
everything goes, and one of
the nice touches as
well that we had.
If I drop back to this screen,
you'll see at the top there is
in fact a little menu item or a
little action item, I should
say, which is going to allow you
to start a music player.
Now, in this case, it's going
to start up Google Music.
Now, one of the really nice
things about this is that you
can do this in your app.
And this makes a lot of sense,
because a lot of the times
when you are going to be using
an app like this, it's going
to be while you're exercising.
You're going to want
to listen to music.
This is pretty common.
So having a quick link to a
music player is a really
useful, a really nice touch.
And you can do this by creating
an intent to launch a
music player like this.
Note that it's changed
slightly in Ice Cream
Sandwich, and you can see both
of the options on screen here.
Then note that this doesn't
specifically
launch Google Music.
The launch intent doesn't
specify a
particular music player.
Any app that's capable of
playing, browsing, or
manipulating music files stored
on the device can
specify the category app music
in its manifest and be
presented as an option when
this intent is fired.
So if you're building a music
player, that's something you
may want to consider when
building your app.
Let's take a look at the next
app that I installed, which is
RunKeeper, from FitnessKeeper.
Now, they've taken the approach
of using their
feature graphic to display
their app name and logo.
And that's perfectly reasonable,
but it lacks the
punch of something more
representative of their brand
rather than just the
branding itself.
Now, the biggest roadblock for
me was the five touches it
took to get from my launcher
to the main screen.
Now, that's a lot of work to do
to get to the point where I
can decide if I even want
to use the app.
Now, when I did get to the home
screen, I felt a little
like I'd walked into a time
warp with old-style
tabs and a title bar.
Now, in fairness, it turns out
that RunKeeper has a new beta.
So I'm going to switch to that,
which hopefully I took a
screenshot of, but I
apparently didn't.
Now, their new design is
definitely more modern.
It's very much the
same navigation
as you can see here.
But they've replaced
the tabs with a
ViewPager-style tab pager.
They've got an action bar.
Now, unfortunately, it looks
like a ViewPager, but it
doesn't swipe.
So that's one of the most
important things that they
need to do to create that
consistency, is make sure that
they can swipe between tabs.
And that's kind of the story for
their entire redesign, is
that it's not really a
change in the app.
It's just cosmetic.
So I would definitely suggest
that they take this
opportunity to rethink some of
the navigation, some of the
structure of the app, as well
as just the raw cosmetics.
Because at the moment, the
layout and navigation is
pretty much unchanged.
And in terms of data and
functionality provided on the
main screen, it's actually
pretty similar to what
Endomondo has with a couple of
really important differences.
Now, before I start exercising
there's no indication of what
information I'll get.
Will it be mapped?
Will it be recording the
time or distance?
I really don't see any of that
before I get started, and that
really makes me reluctant to
get started in my exercise
knowing that I really don't know
what's going to happen,
how much of what I want to be
recorded is going to be.
And a lot of users are like
me, and they'll install a
bunch of options all at once
before jumping in and seeing
what each has to offer.
So as a result, it's important
that you give potential users
as clear a picture of what you
offer without them having to
do anything.
Now, they've also put a lot of
emphasis on how I'm receiving
my location.
And the input type is the first
thing I'm presented
with, and 99% of the time
that's going to be GPS,
probably consolidated with Wi-Fi
and cell ID, if that's
accurate enough.
In practice, for an app like
this, you're going to want to
listen for every location update
that comes through
using a patent a lot like this
one, as described in the
Location Strategies API Guide
section "Maintaining a current
best estimate." This is going to
let you listen for updates
from every location source,
after which you can determine
the most likely current
position.
This is really important for
apps like these, where a few
small offsets for a few small
seconds can turn a 10-mile
jog, into a 100-mile odyssey.
And you know what I mean.
You've all seen someone's
hilarious social media post
with a massive spike in distance
where they appear to
have jogged across a river or up
a mountain range thanks to
some GPS reflection error.
So don't be the punchline
to a joke.
Try and sanity check all of your
location results so that
your users are able to get the
best possible location at any
given time.
Now, otherwise, the app works
in much the same way.
You hit start, stop.
One of the strange things is
once you hit stop, you get
prompted as to whether or not
you want to save your results.
Now, that should be a given.
You should always save anything
the user does and
give them an option to delete
something rather than an
option to save it.
The other thing I noticed is
that they have map pins, which
look strikingly similar to the
ones in iOS, which in and of
itself isn't a problem, except
that it looks a little bit
weird on an Android device to
have these pins which look
like they come from a different
operating system.
One good piece of news for
this app, which I really
liked, is that it does send
everything to a server without
you having to log in.
Now, logging in to the
other apps was
actually a real hassle.
It took a lot of time and
effort, having to exchange
credentials, create accounts,
send email addresses, all this
sort of stuff, whereas here,
it auto-syncs without me
having to do anything,
which is actually
a really nice touch.
Now, while I was navigating
around this app, I actually
noticed a couple of
strange artifacts.
And one is the way that they
are using a web view to
present a lot of
their screens.
And that in and of itself
is perfectly fine.
There's no problem with that.
But the implementation of the
way that they've done it is
making the zoom controls become
visible at various times.
Now, you can make sure that you
turn off both the built-in
zoom controls and the visibility
of the on-screen
zoom, the ability to pinch zoom
as well as the ability to
zoom using the controls by
turning off the zoom controls.
That should be enough to
make it all go away.
But if you hit both of these
methods here, then that will
definitely make sure that there
are no ability for the
user to zoom on a display which
you've clearly designed
not to zoom.
Another strange artifact, is
this modal dialog that tells
me that my GPS result
is pretty crappy.
Now, I don't want to see this
unless it's preventing the app
from being able to do
what it needs to do.
So you really don't want to pop
it up unless I've already
hit the Start button and
definitely not randomly while
I'm just navigating the app.
Now, last but certainly
not least, let's
take a look at runtastic.
Now, leaving the strange
capitalization choices that
they've made aside, they've got
a pretty good landing page
on Google Play.
Like Endomondo, they've used
a feature graphic that
immediately makes you feel
like you understand the
purpose of the product and the
sorts of people that they're
marketing towards.
And their logo and icon is
pretty good, though I would
really love to see them lose
that rounded rectangle and
choose a more distinctive
silhouette.
And if you kind of look at it,
you can see that maybe even as
simple as removing the blue, so
you've just got the running
man on the black ribbon, would
look kind of awesome and
definitely distinctive.
So that's something that you
guys may want to consider.
Now, once we get to the main
screen, we can see that it's
actually pretty similar to
Endomondo, which is great.
Clearly, there is a best
practice here, which I think a
lot of these apps are going
to move towards.
Straightaway, we can see what
we'll be recording, and
there's a big green button to
let me know to get started.
And as a bonus, runtastic also
displays details like the
sunrise/sunset time, the current
weather forecast,
temperature, all of which
is a really nice bonus.
And in fact, those extra details
are also included in
my workout data.
So I can see whether it was
sunny, cloudy, hot, cold as I
did each workout, which I think
is a really nice touch
and provides a little
bit more context
for your daily workout.
And they've included them on
screen here in a way that
isn't overly intrusive, which
is always a nice touch.
So the functionality provided
on the main page is really
similar, but they've made a
couple of specific design
choices which I think risks
users falling into the "you're
holding it wrong" trap,
which is something you
always want to avoid.
So the main thing you'll notice
here is that there's no
obvious indication of what
your touch targets are.
And in fact, as soon as I
started touching things on the
screen, I tended to
get it wrong.
So I'd hit each of
the different--
like duration time things to try
and get pace or calories
or anything like that and
nothing happened.
And so it's not until you try
to hit the smallest touch
target on the entire UI, the
tiny cog in the middle, that
you get that functionality.
You hit that, and then you're
able to modify them.
And again, what that does is
pops up a really, really small
bar of icons, which lets you
choose which of the different
settings that you
want to view.
So again, it's tiny, tiny touch
targets, which don't
tell you what they are.
And this could be a real
problem, because I'm using
this app while I'm stretching,
while I'm jogging, preparing
to start my exercise regime.
You really want to have things
be big, easy to touch, and
obvious to know what you're
going to touch.
And it's kind of the same thing
here once you get down
to the workout type
and activity type.
It's not obvious that
they're buttons.
You click on them, and
it pops up a dialogue
with small text in--
closely spaced, and you really
want to make sure that that's
easy for people to use and easy
for people to navigate.
And it's the same as the
big green Go button.
It's clearly a button,
but it's not
actually an Android button.
So all these things taken
together really puts you in a
situation where you're having
to think before
you can use the app.
You're having to figure out
how do I get it to do the
things that I want it to do?
And for an app like this, where
you want people to be
able to get started quickly
and easily, that
can be a real problem.
So once we get going, they've
again made a really
interesting choice.
And unfortunately, I can't
show it to you right now.
But once you start your workout,
you actually have to
unlock the screen before you're
able to do anything.
And in fact, if you don't, so
if you just try and hit the
Pause or Stop button on your
workout, you get a toast that
pops up saying, you're
doing it wrong.
You have to unlock
the screen first.
Now, I didn't even notice--
excuse me.
I didn't even notice that
the first time that I
went to stop a workout.
I just hit Stop, turned off the
screen, and when I opened
up the app later on, I noticed
that it was still going.
Now, a good tip for UX general
is that if you're using a
toast to tell your users that
they should have done
something else when they did
what they did, you're probably
the one doing it wrong
rather than them.
So it's really important to
figure out how users are
actually using your app
and make sure that you
optimize for that.
In this case, they've made the
assumption that the most
likely thing that may happen
is a user will accidentally
stop something on the screen.
Now, for most users, chances are
they would just turn the
screen off when they don't
want to touch anything.
So they're better off relying
on the phone than having
something built into your app.
OK, so once we finish the
workout, the experience is
pretty great.
From this point onwards,
I probably prefer
runtastic to Endomondo.
The contextual information you
get around things like
weather, relative speed, the
way that they display your
speed along your track on
the map is really great.
There is an option there to
choose between Save and Done
once you've finished
a workout which is
a little bit confusing.
As I said before, saving should
already have happened.
It should just be a
case of, yes I've
finished reviewing this.
Let me go back to
the main screen.
Another comment I had is
that their setting
screen is really complex.
Again, you're sort of in this
pattern of having to really
read a lot of text to figure out
how to do stuff, which is
something you should try and
avoid in apps like this.
Now, the next few points apply
to more than just runtastic.
So I want to make sure that
the shame gets applied
broadly, and the credit where
it's due as well.
But I think what we're trying
to focus on here on "The App
Clinic" is ways that you
can improve your app.
So we're going to try to
highlight a couple of the
things which could be done
perhaps a little bit better.
Now, first off, both runtastic
and Endomondo have a little
surprise waiting in their
overflow menu.
It is, in fact, an
Exit button.
Now, those of you who know me
know that my initial reaction
to seeing an Exit button is
something a lot like this.
I chose not to destroy
our studio room once
again to make a point.
But in fact, you can find my
full thoughts on Exit buttons
in Android apps and why they
shouldn't exist by watching
Table Flip on YouTube where
I lay out exactly why this
anti-patent fills me with an
impenetrable darkness.
But in some ways, I
guess I get it.
These apps represent kind
of a special case.
They should definitely keep
running while they're in the
background.
And they all do use
notifications to let us know
that that's exactly
what's happening.
So given that, they have two
choices to figure out what the
right use case is.
Both of them involve getting rid
of something called Exit.
They need to decide if they
are more like turn-by-turn
navigation or if they're more
like a music player.
Now, for the sake of argument,
I'm going to say that they
should be more like music
players, which really means
that I only want to see
a notification.
I only want the app to continue
to run in the
background while I'm
doing the work.
So as soon as I hit Play or
Start, then by all means, pop
up a notification, start an
ongoing service to make sure
that the app doesn't go away.
But then as soon as I hit Stop,
as soon as my workout is
finished, then I want the
app to behave just
as any other app.
So hitting Home or hitting Back
out of the app should
take it out of memory, should
stop GPS updates, and just
basically give me my phone back
as though the app was
never running.
At the moment, you have this
tendency of like I just opened
the app, checked it out, and I
have this icon saying or this
notification saying, hey,
actually, it's still running.
And that's not a great
user experience.
I don't want to have to figure
out how to make it stop.
I already did make it stop
by ending my workout.
While we're talking about
notifications, I think there's
really a fantastic opportunity
to make these notifications
even more useful.
Now, at the moment, all three
of the apps have a simple
"click here to return to the
app" text within the
notification.
Now, why not be a little
bit more adventurous?
I'd love to see rich
notifications with actions
that let me pause or end my
workout directly from the
notification shade.
I'd also love to see some more
details on my workout here,
things like duration,
distance traveled.
Basically anything that I've
selected to look at on the app
home screen, why not stick it
in the notification as well?
I think that really would
present a really rich
experience for your users.
And in fact, when we looked at
stopwatch apps just a few
weeks ago, we saw a few examples
of rich notifications
being used to great effect,
where you could basically use
the entire stopwatch app without
actually having to
launch the app.
The other thing missing
from all three apps
was a tablet layout.
In fact, only RunKeeper even
supported the option of using
the app in landscape mode.
Now, I know that these apps were
originally created with
the thought of having a fitness
companion on your phone.
I'm sure no one really imagined
strapping a Nexus 7
to your arm as you go jogging.
But what about using
it at the gym or if
you're using it rowing?
Then suddenly, a tablet isn't
quite as ridiculous an option.
Now step one is creating a great
responsive design that
means that the app will work
great on whatever device I
happen to be using no
matter what the
orientation or screen size.
So that's where I'd start,
really just make sure that I
can use the app in a way that
doesn't frustrate me on a
tablet device.
Step two is creating a great
tablet-specific experience.
Now, even if I'm not planning
to take my Nexus 10 rowing,
I'd love to go through my
workouts while I'm sitting on
my couch not working out.
Whether that's reviewing the
tracks I've run, analyzing the
data, sort of doing all that
stuff to figure out what is my
fitness level, all of that stuff
will be fantastic to do
directly on a tablet.
And in fact, that's one of
the things that mint.com
discovered when they created
an optimized tablet
experience.
It turns out that tablet users
are more deeply engaged and
more likely to spend time
within the app.
So Mint responded by creating
a richer experience,
specifically for tablet users
designed around data analysis
rather than data entry.
So whereas on the Mint phone
app you'd go through and
actually put in all of your
purchases, keep track of your
budget, within the tablet app
you would be able to go
through and see exactly where
you've been spending money and
do that deep analysis.
And I think that there's really
an opportunity for
these apps to do something
similar to drive their user
engagement and really
get people
addicted to their service.
So before we sign off, let's
take a quick look at the
prescriptions that we have for
each app to help them move
towards a pure Android
experience.
So we'll start off
with Endomondo.
So first off, kill
the Exit button.
It should keep running
only while
we're tracking a workout.
They've actually got
kind of a bug.
So I made a note to say that
they have an issue with their
navigation drop-down list on
their homepage, where it
doesn't have a drop-down icon
to tell you it's a list.
Now, as it happens, that doesn't
seem to be the case on
all devices.
So that's just a bug
to take a look at.
Similarly, the settings that
you've got within the
navigation drop-down should be
in the overflow menu rather
than within the main activities
navigation.
No tablet view, forced
portrait--
please don't ever force
portrait mode.
I would like to use my tablet in
landscape mode, and as soon
as you lock it to portrait, I
feel like you're basically
saying you can't use
this app on the
device that you're using.
And it's a 7-meg download.
I'm not entirely sure why
it's a 7-meg download.
That seems like a lot for
what the app is doing.
So maybe consider what you're
packaging in there and how
many of those assets you need
to have on the device.
In terms of runtastic pro,
10-meg download.
Seriously?
Why are these apps so big?
It feels like you could drop a
lot of that without having to
lose a lot of the assets
that you're using.
The fact that it takes five
clicks to get to the beginning
of the app the first time you
run it is a real turn off.
Every time I have to click the
button again, I'm that much
more tempted to just hit Back,
go to the Play Store, and
download something faster.
You want to update your
UI a little bit.
There's some iPhone-y looking
buttons, which just kind of
look out of place on Android.
And same--
Exit button--
same as Endomondo.
Please get rid of
the Exit button.
The setting screen in the
overall UI isn't as intuitive
as it could be.
I mean, it's a great app.
It has a lot of the features
that I really want to see.
It just feels like I have to do
a little bit too much work
to be able to use it.
Build with tablet mode
would be fantastic.
Again, don't lock me into
portrait if you don't have to.
And yeah, maybe see if you can
do something about the logo.
I think you're like 90%
of the way there
with something awesome.
You could just get rid of the
rounded corners, and suddenly,
you've got something which would
be a really distinctive
and really great Android logo.
And finally, RunKeeper.
So here, it's great to see that
you guys are doing a UI
overhaul to bring in
some of those new
patents like Action Bar.
I definitely think it's an
opportunity for you to maybe
look a little bit more deeply
into the structure of the app
and the navigation, but it's
definitely heading along the
right path, so keep that up.
Do get rid of that modal
dialogue for missing location.
That is just death.
And the menu button of shame,
which is actually a full-blown
menu button of shame, clicking
it does nothing.
So make sure that that goes away
as part of your redesign.
It also takes like three or four
clicks to go from opening
the app to being able
to do anything.
So again, try and to speed up
that first user flow from
downloading it from Google Play
and running it the first
time should be as quick
as possible.
So that's all for us today.
Apologies for the technical
snafus, which meant we
couldn't do any of the live
stuff, but I think hopefully
we were able to share most of
the information that we
intended to.
Don't forget to tune in to
Roman, Nick, and Adam for
"Android Design in Action"
on Tuesday.
We'll all be setting their
design skills loose on some of
the apps that we looked
at today, hopefully.
There will be no "App
Clinic" next week.
It's celebrating Turkey
Day here in the US.
And we're going to be spending
some time trying to find and
rescue Ian from the backwoods,
hopefully with a minimum
number of his limbs sawn off
with a pocket knife.
When we're back, device
profile apps will
be up on the table.
We'll be looking at apps like
Tasker and NFC Task Launcher.
So if you've got a device
profile app that you'd like us
to take a look at, be sure
to hit our Trello page at
bit.ly/AppClinicTrello and get
your votes and nominations in.
I want to quickly throw a
question over to Dan and find
out if there are any questions
or comments from folks on any
of the feeds which need
to be responded to.
DANIEL: So we have
two questions.
The first one is "What's the
best way to integrate social
aspects into these types of
apps?" Go ahead, and I'll ask
the second one later.
RETO MEIER: Sure.
That's actually a good question
and something which I
didn't touch on.
But at least two of the apps,
Endomondo and runstastic, both
have deep integration with
social features.
Now, they've done it
a pretty good way.
And you can see that a lot of
people will share their
workouts via things like
Facebook and Twitter.
And likewise, Endomondo has the
ability to actually cheer
your friends on or compete
against them.
I think these are all really
rich uses of social circles.
It's been proven, in fact, that
with things like anything
goal setting, particularly
things like exercise, having
people hold you accountable is
a really great way of being
able to help motivate you and
keep your willpower up.
So I think the key to social
integration here on a
philosophical level is to
find ways to help you be
accountable to your friends
and create something
competitive with people, which
is always a real help when it
comes to things fitness.
In terms of practical
implementation details, I
think the key is really to try
and make it as smooth a path
as possible.
So whatever social network
you're choosing to integrate
with, you want to make sure that
that sign-in flow is as
smooth as possible.
Like I said, I actually had
some trouble creating an
account on Endomondo, and I want
this to be as much of a
one-click process as possible.
So whether that's signing into
Facebook, Twitter, G+, or
anything else which provides
you with some of the
functionality you need, you
really want to try and make
that process as smooth
as possible.
And ideally, make sure
it doesn't block.
So I want to be able to use
the app with no social
features and with no account,
and then see the reasons why
hooking this into my social
network would be beneficial.
And then once you've done that,
you want to make sure as
well you're not doing
anything obnoxious.
Make sure that you always give
the users an option as to
whether they want to share
something on their social
network or not.
And in fact, one of the apps,
I believe it was runtastic,
has a share icon, but it doesn't
actually let you share
anything unless you're
logged in.
And that's something you
want to avoid as well.
It's great to have the social
features built in directly to
those websites, if you can, just
to lower the friction.
But even if I haven't chosen
to sign in with Facebook, I
still want to be able to share
it using any of the apps that
I have installed, which may
include things like Facebook,
Twitter, or G+.
So you want to make sure that
you don't limit yourself just
to those tight integrations
and make sure that just
standard sharing across regular
Android intent-based
sharing works as well.
DANIEL: Cool.
And the last question that we
have is "Have any of the apps
that we've reviewed on 'The App
Clinic' made it to Pure
Android yet?"
RETO MEIER: So good
news on that.
We have been spending some time
going through the apps
which we have looked at.
And we have looked at a lot of
apps over the last year.
So it's taken us a bit of time,
but we have I think two
or three candidates which we're
just going through now
within the team to make sure
that we're all satisfied with.
And we'll hopefully have
something to announce in the
week after Thanksgiving.
So not this week, but the week
after, we will hopefully be
inducting the first of our apps
into the Pure Android App
Clinic collection.
All right, so thank you very
much for watching everyone.
That's all we've got
time for today.
Join us in a couple of weeks for
the next episode of "The
App Clinic." Until then, I'm
Reto Meier, and this has been
"The App Clinic." Thank
you for watching.